hello
i am daryl haggard
and i am here to tell you about black
holes
so i really enjoy some call-in response
especially since now we're here coming
toward the second to last talk um so i'm
going to ask you questions a few
questions over the course of my talk and
i would like you to respond if at all
possible
so my first question to you is what
planet are we on
awesome okay so we're off to a very good
start um
at the end of this presentation what i
would like you all to say to me
is if i tell you that black holes are
truly awesome and that they really don't
suck i would like you to be able to
respond to me that black holes don't
suck and really believe what you're
saying so that's my objective here today
i want you to know that black holes
really they are not cosmic vacuum
cleaners they don't go rogue around the
galaxy and gobble things up that's not
what they're about and that's not what
they're up to
i would like you to think of them as
very massive objects with very excellent
manners
so black holes are truly and very very
well governed by our theory of general
relativity so far despite many tests
that we have put these two we have never
seen deviations away from general
relativity and they seem to really be
guided by this kind of amazing theory
that governs a lot of what we think
is going on with gravity so you've heard
a little bit about gravity from other
speakers today
and i would like you to think now about
the mass involved in black holes to
remember that they are indeed truly very
very small but they are still
spectacular
and so i'd like you to start thinking a
little bit about the awesomeness of
black holes in the context of this
really amazing image that i think might
appear oh that's up to me i guide the
image yes okay here's the black hole um
so i have you all seen this picture
before
it's kind of an awesome thing to be an
astronomer and have a lot of people say
yes when you show them a picture of a
black hole that's a new thing that we
can actually show you an image and be
able to tell you a little bit about
what's going on with this incredible
image of a black hole
so they are really awesome creatures
this is the very first picture we've
ever been able to take of the photons
swirling around very close to the event
horizon of a supermassive black hole so
i'm going to use this image as my prop
for a minute to help you understand a
little bit my favorite definition of
what a black hole is
so i like this very toy model there's a
lot more complications to it than this
but think of a baseball
and what happens when i daryl haggard
throw a baseball
be honest with me
i see some people doing this that's
literally what would happen it would
just fall down right so the baseball it
falls back down to the surface of the
earth i'm not that strong i'm actually
i'm i've got a pretty terrible throwing
arm so
this baseball
falls back down because of the gravity
of our planet and so it's experiencing
our gravitational pull the planet's
gravitational pull but it turns out that
if i could accelerate just put a little
rocket on the back of that baseball and
accelerate it up to 11 kilometers per
second or just a little bit more i can
actually get that baseball out into
orbit or even
completely out into outer space off the
surface of our planet so 11 kilometers
per second if that's not your you know
ball of wax maybe you prefer queens
units that's something like 25 000 miles
per hour right our cars don't go that
fast but sometimes our rocket ships do
so the thing about a black hole is that
that velocity that escape velocity the
velocity you would need to give a
particle for it to escape off the
surface of that body
is faster than the speed of light
so light is trapped inside the black
hole and light is the fastest velocity
those photons are traveling at the
fastest velocity we know of it's a
fundamental constant so light stuck in
there and that's why we call them black
holes but this image is a picture of all
of the stuff just outside
the black hole just outside the event
horizon the black hole these are the
photons and the hot gas and the hot
material swirling just outside the
horizon of this black hole
so
let me tell you just a little bit more
about this particular black hole um this
one we like to use relative units in
astronomy so we often measure things in
terms of other things because otherwise
the numbers are just a little bit hard
to hold in your mind so this black hole
is 60
65 whatever 6.5 billion times the mass
of our own sun so that's a lot of mass
but that mass is packed into a really
small space so i'm borrowing this
cartoon from xkcd which some of you
might recognize that's a little picture
of our sun and pluto's orbit and the
voyager satellite which is the farthest
thing we've ever managed to throw out
into space and that scale is
superimposed on this supermassive black
hole so 6.5 billion times the mass of
our sun crammed into a space roughly the
size of our solar system that's what
makes it a black hole if that still
doesn't quite kind of match your
intuition let me give you another
example here's a really small number
relatively speaking
this is three millionths of the mass of
our sun anybody know what that might be
i made you say it before
earth okay that's exactly right so our
earth has about three millionths of the
mass of our sun but the earth could be a
black hole too if you could just smash
everything your mom your dad some of the
moms and dads in the audience tonight
all the trees all the oceans all the
buildings all the continents into
something the size of a sugar cube
that would also be a black hole it's not
that our earth all of a sudden sucked
everything in it's just that you
compacted all of the mass down into a
very small volume and that's what gives
you a very high escape velocity so i'm
just going to let us now take a little
journey to wrap up my time since i'm
running out this is a beautiful image
made
to help you walk you into the universe
where this amazing supermassive black
hole resides at the heart of the
so-called virgo cluster of galaxies so
we're zooming toward the constellation
virgo in the night sky and there's a
massive cluster of galaxies is the
nearest structure of galaxies to our own
milky way galaxy and in the inside of
this incredible cluster of galaxies
there's a particularly massive galaxy
right in the center called m87 and you
can already see here that through other
pictures we can see a jet zooming out of
the black hole and as we zoom in a
little bit further we can actually see
that jet structure continue all the way
down toward the very very heart of this
galaxy this jet is kind of pointed
toward our line of sight which is a
little hard to make out in these images
but this is all real data zooming in
closer and closer and closer until we
reach the event horizon so not only does
this black hole not suck it is throwing
material and energy out into the
universe at scales that are enormous
compared to the size of the galaxy that
hosts the black hole
go let me just show you one last little
video here which is actually going to
show you the photons in orbit around the
black hole just to further make the
point that not only does it not suck in
mass and dust and people and astronauts
the black hole doesn't even suck in the
photons these are simulated paths now of
photons in orbit around a supermassive
black hole like the one that we saw in
m87 and you'll see that they're bending
just like the light in through your
glasses gets bent to focus on your
retina the black hole does bend the
photons just a little bit due to
gravitational lensing and make this
beautiful ring image that we see so it's
not sucking the photons in but it does
redirect them a little bit to give us
this really amazing kind of structure
that we've now viewed all right so
that's all she wrote so when i tell you
that i think black holes are awesome you
are now going to tell me
thank you